Hubbard I'm melody no call me business
the real issue is the dire poverty of
much of the world and what we can do
about it and the current a debate has
two poles one poll says well the real
answer in the West is we need to spend
some certain fraction of GDP for targets
maybe point seven percent on aid to me
as an economist that pole is always some
odd we typically measure success or
failure not how much you spend on the
other end or well-meaning people who say
you know look the past 40 years of a bit
of failure and they're largely correct
and suppose they're talking about
economic aid so let's stop doing it I
don't think that's the right moral
answer and I certainly don't think it's
the right pick and i'm a cancer we can
do this
short and the ideas really in two steps
first is to step back and say what works
and if you look at economies that have
become prosperous whether it's
historically or in the modern period
it's about invigorating the local
business center that's how the United
States got rich that's how the West got
rich that's how modern growth miracles
in Asia and even in parts of Africa have
happened one of the things we could do
there is to focus much more economic aid
on local business in there in the book
be a trap I argued that we should go to
the software or Marshall Plan people
think of the marshall plan for europe
and 1947 252 is being a grand aid scheme
it wasn't that at all the Marshall Plan
loan money to local businesses it was
only when that money got paid back that
it went to governments and the entire
plan was run by business people Europe
then is not the same as African now but
that same software could work
well I think we first start with the big
picture of institutional reform
President Bush implemented what was
called the Millennium Challenge account
which was a very good idea trigger
condition USA on institutional reforms
that are pro-business we need to keep
that but then we need to get the money
directly to local businesses and the way
to do that would be to establish
regional offices throughout sub-saharan
Africa some countries specifics on
region-specific offices would compete
for allocations of money based on
reforms money would be given directly to
local businesses through local business
people through private equity through US
business a and when that money is repaid
it can either be given to governments if
that's the goal or given directly in
some recycling to other businesses the
marshall plan offers us a way to do that
there are countries in sub-saharan
Africa that are already making good
progress along these lines Rwanda comes
to mind is a great example the World
Bank actually tries to measure the ease
of doing business in a country so called
doing business indicators rwanda has
actually done very well at this in the
past couple of years moving up 60
notches so there are some countries
already doing this
I think so a lot of the corruption that
arises in the present aid system is
because so much of 8 clothes go directly
through government organizations highly
concentrated payments that are prone to
corruption direct lending to individual
businesses yes there will be some
corruption yes there will be some
leakage is nothing is perfect but I
think it will be a lot less than we see
in the current system and you're
building a constituency of small and
medium sized business people with inner
powerful advocates against grouchy
well the Millennium Challenge account
started from a simple premise from
economic research in the past 10 or 20
years that there are some institutional
changes that lead to growth for example
having an independent judiciary
enforcement of simple debt contracts and
the rule of law institutional does it
make it easier for a business person to
operate over somebody can lend you money
and get paid back so the idea the
Millennium Challenge account was let's
take a pot of money and go to countries
receiving a is if you'd like additional
money you need to make these
institutional changes and that's a very
good idea except I think that too much
of the money was going directly to
government so missing the point about
how to directly get money in the hands
of the small business medium-sized
business sector so what I propose any
aid trap is to take essentially the idea
of the Millennium Challenge account a
step further why don't we go directly to
the local businesses having established
institutional forms
I'm fascinated by China's goals in
Africa it's essentially in our modern
time a version of what was the big game
a century or so ago of intrigue of
domination and I think what China has
done is made a bargain that is almost
colonial we will give you large amounts
of a ten-million-dollar promise from
China but an exchange we're interested
principally in locking up resources that
help us the Chinese in our growth very
little effort to promote african
business now I think for the u.s.
there's a double win here possible one
is to say look in terms of the economics
if you want growth in sub-saharan Africa
it's not going to be with special deals
with China it would be what invigorates
local business and second what better
foil for the u.s. to be the giver that
says no we're about local African
business we're not about taking
resources I think that's a real room for
us
I think that they're obviously the
Congress has many priorities at the
moment and this probably isn't the comp
one two or three but I do think there's
interest in both the Congress and the
administration for the simple reason
that I think President Obama would like
to take bold action here I think he
believes it's an imperative and I share
that view please shackled a bit by the
fact that the u.s. really can't spend
the amount of money that many advocates
are talking about this is an alternative
view for him if he didn't do this i'm
not sure what he would
sure well outside of Africa the two
growth miracles of the very recent
couple of decades have been India and
China both of those miracles have
involved opening and the very
significant growth of domestic business
much like broke miracles we've seen for
centuries in Africa today in sub-saharan
Africa two countries in recent years
have done extraordinarily well and
moving up in the doing business
indicators a one is Rwanda and the
others Mauritius in both cases it's been
leaders that have been very focused on
the business sector both importing
multinational investment but also
importantly encouraging local business
this has been done I think it would be a
good idea for example for the World Bank
to take small groups of African
countries may be starting with co Mesa
in eastern and southern Africa bring
together the best practices and try to
encourage this pro-business attitude
well if I were to look at the problem of
what went wrong and the financial crisis
and link into business schools there are
many causes for the financial crisis but
I think one was a set of business
leaders who couldn't connect wouldn't
connect the dots by which I mean a lot
of what was going on in the world was
clearly in front of people's face the
mispricing of risk the global factors
that were involved but many business
leaders were so expertly focused on
narrow areas they didn't see that big
picture I'm not sure we described that
as arrogance i'm not sure i've described
it as a lack of integrity I would
describe it more as a lack of historical
context and global context and I think
that's something business schools could
do a better job of something we're
trying to very much in Columbia
well even before the crisis we had
implemented a new curriculum that
brought in a sense for financial history
in business history and of international
trends so we were doing that before
after the crisis we really focused us a
lot by giving students much more of a
sense of perspectives across disciplines
in their classes with an idea toward
getting them to think in a bigger
picture way I think it's too easy to go
to business school and become an expert
in something finance accounting
operations I remember interest you
without thinking about the very broad
platform for leadership and I think that
was part of the financial crisis I don't
think it was most of it but i think it
was part of
well in a perverse sense for people like
me the crisis had a nice effect because
frankly this is what I do research on a
models of so-called financial
accelerators what happens when you get
into financial crises what happens to
investment what happens to consumer
spending a lot of people like me have
done work in this area have generally
relied on historical episodes because
that's where we've seen crises so now we
have you know unfortunately an episode
during the modern period what we know in
those periods is that when you get into
a financial crisis the inside net worth
of borrowers becomes very very important
this is what we saw in the collapse of
consumer spending is consumer network
decline and in the business sector as
the cost of external financing became
very high as credit spreads became very
high we also though have a sense of what
to do in an environment like this very
aggressive monetary policy is part of
the answer we did that with the Federal
Reserve tax cuts can be part of the
answer so I think policy has been very
aggressive today much more aggressive
than it was saying Japan in the 1990s or
in the US and the 1930s taking a crisis
that was very bad but making it not as
bad as it could
I'm very worried about this we have
essentially a set of deficit problems in
the country the very short run I'm not
sure that we should worry so much about
the extra deficit that was used to help
attack the financial crisis I think it's
very important to be very aggressive
give the Federal Reserve any
administration credit there I would have
done Brooks a different set of things in
the administration but their basic
thrust I'm ok with going toward the
medium term though we've seen a built-up
both from the Bush administration and
now from the Obama administration in
significant levels of spending that will
have to be paid for with future taxes
and that deficit is a real problem and
then the third deficit the one that
scares me the most is the long-term
entitlement deficit because of our
promises for Social Security and
Medicare if you just let the clock run
one generation 25 years we would be
spending about ten percentage points of
u.s. gdp more on just social security
and medicare than the day-to-day and
given that the whole federal tax share
today is nineteen percent of GDP and
then sixty percent tax increases for
everybody that's obviously not going to
happen and so we're going to have to
come to grips with this at some point
bond markets will worry about this and
it will be a problem for interest rates
because bond market participants will
realize the US has been a very difficult
problem these debt levels if I were say
one thing the president obama right now
will be focus focus focus on getting
that long-term deficit down
well we have to figure out what our
expenditures are going to be your the
first order or fiscal decisions how much
you spend then you have a decision if
you use taxes or borrow and we're
borrowings just eat your taxes I think
for the u.s. our levels of spending
promises for the future again
particularly entitlement programs are so
big we really can't raise taxes enough
to pay for that I don't think we can't
buy arithmetic that the amounts are so
good sixty seventy percent that's just
not going to happen even crater economic
growth so I think we really have to talk
a lot about how to scale back some of
these programs going forward and do so
in a way that keeps the least well off
among us fine but asked for some
sacrifices frankly from those of us with
a law
well I think that's what sarbanes-oxley
did well was to focus managerial
attention on accounting yet frankly in
the post sarbanes-oxley period you've
seen spectacular failures so it's not
getting people to dot i's and cross T's
isn't enough we really need to think
about risk management the area that I
think was not treated well enough in
sarbanes-oxley is the whole idea of
enterprise risk management with your
financial institution or a non financial
institution does the leadership of the
farm as the board of directors really
understand where the risks are buried in
firm I think in some of the recent
failures the answer to that question
might well be now
and that's so sure I think yeah I come
from Columbia where we have a whole
franchise teaching alternatives to the
efficient market hypothesis our students
are a little bit different they come up
with behavioral approaches value
investing efficient markets is this one
thing I think that there was a tendency
by many policymakers and business people
to think of market prices must be better
than any available alternative I think
that there is clearly you need to look
at bubbles I don't think you can just
wait till after the fact and say oh my
gosh that was a bubble let's clean up
the housing bubble was quite clearly a
bubble I think it was noticed by a lot
of people was noticed in real time and
does raise clear policy concerns I don't
think you can just say the market price
Calysta to run
I'm concerned about the politicization
of the Fed the Fed has been any us a
great institution is a central bank both
in conducting monetary policy and also
in being a great lender of last resort I
worry that drawing the Fed too much into
financial regulatory battles puts it
squarely in politics and that's clearly
an area where the Congress should have
and does have opinions I think the
committee on capital markets regulation
on part of his has issued an opinion
that having a an umbrella financial
services agency much like the United
Kingdom or Japan makes much more sense
for overall financial regulation and let
the feds stick the monetary policy
well I've always been sort of an odd man
out in Washington on this I don't
particularly think we should be
encouraging home ownership neither do i
think we should discourage home
ownership seems to me that's an economic
decision for each individual to make as
a factual matter if you look at the
public policies that we've taken to
encourage home ownership of mortgage
interest deduction direct credit
interventions and so on there's very
little evidence to suggest that we
achieve higher all ownership rates in
some countries that don't have a
mortgage interest deduction for example
our northern neighbor in Canada so I'm
not sure that it's worth the candle and
we know that what we put in through
fannie mae and freddie mac you know has
led to very large exposures to taxpayers
so i think this is a question we really
have to come to grips with ailee's don't
think there's a moral superiority to
homeownership I live that because I rent
I think it's it's multiple factors I
think our three causes but they do all
relate to policy just not all the same
policy maker one is the global
imbalances that I did came about because
of decisions in MIDI emerging Asian
economies to accumulate massive dollar
reserves for their own policy objectives
China clearly elite example their second
was u.s. monetary policy in the period
say 2003-2005 was clearly way too easy
or gasoline on the flames of an emerging
bubble and the third is the fact that it
was too easy to do regulatory arbitrage
the capital standards word as good as we
thought some regulators clearly weren't
up to the task so I think all three of
those were very important factors so
they are policy contributions but
they're not all 11 persons failure
I don't I think there's some very tough
questions the Fed and other regulators
will have to look at I don't think that
glass-steagall the separation of
commercial and investment banking would
have been terribly helpful here in fact
there were some pure banks that got into
trouble there was some trading houses
that got into trouble and in fact where
we had rescues is precisely bringing
together banking in mom banking's or not
sure that helps there are also concerns
people out of about you know maybe
should we draw bright lines about the
size of banks not particularly persuaded
that that's useful either I think there
isn't going to be a simple answer I do
think it involves better risk management
I think it involves stronger attention
to capital requirements but no I don't
think last thing
well I sense the Congressional
frustration at the bed I think the kids
wandering into politics is bound to get
the Congress's attention you know
congressman Walz introduced this bill
how many times do not much success and
so now I think the reason is success has
happened now is the Fed has become a bit
more political too political in my view
having said that I don't think the poll
bill is the right answer the Fed of
course already is audited in a common
sense of that term my concern would be
Congress attempting to conduct its own
monetary policy by pushing the Fed
around that I think it's a decidedly
I think that chairman Bernanke's
response to the financial crisis has
been both bold and experimenting while
one doesn't necessarily agree with every
single thing the Fed has done I like the
fact that the Fed has been bold during
the crisis the mild criticism I might
have is that going into the crisis the
Fed didn't particularly see a lot of the
danger signs or how large it would be
but many it comes shared that view at
the time so I don't think one can blame
the fed / safe
well first there will be financial
crises I would love to tell you the
world's different i don't believe that
we've had a history of financial crises
in fact i think not paying attention to
that history is part of what made us
vulnerable I don't think government
actions to date make it less likely that
we have a financial crisis I think what
could help would be some broader
regulatory reforms but I don't really
see the Congress being serious attention
well it is what you known from the work
that Carmen and can vid is that
typically in the aftermath of the
bursting own bubble or financial crisis
government debt rises as government's
trying to clean up the pieces in many
countries that's led to a debt crisis
whether there's a debt crisis is a story
about both supply and demand it's clear
that the spline debt has gone up the
question really is what about domestic
debt holders and foreign holders
willingness the whole debt and that
seems to need a bigger question I am
very worried if we stay on the present
fiscal path that we will have a day of
reckoning in that sense I definitely
agree with the reinhart-rogoff pieces